Es ist vollbracht diesen läuft sapinas wohl vor einigen stunden
ausgestoßen tesla hat endlich sein produktionsziel erreicht es war ein langer weg und hat auch allen masc an seine grenzen gebracht will
elektromobilität ist es ein riesiger schritt
e-autos werden so zum massenprodukt mit welchen ungewöhnlichen maßnahmen er dieses ziel erreicht hat jetzt bei klicks um science-fiction
herzlich willkommen bei denen mars chroniken heute übrigens aus meinem gästezimmer am cern in genf
Es war ein langer und ziemlich steiniger weg schon vor monaten wollte maske ist geschafft haben
5000 models in der woche zu fertigen doch monatelang mit der er diesen ziel hinterher und zum schluss wurde sogar ein saboteur
entdeckt der wohl für brände in der produktion des models wie verantwortlich war es war eine harte zeit für macht er selbst hatte es
produktionszelle genannt ihnen musk musste sogar in der tesla verbringt
übernachten um die probleme in der produktion zu lösen dabei hatte alles so gut angefangen was kaufte sogar
2016 mit der eifeler firma grohmann einen deutschen maschinenbauer der
produktionsanlagen für die autoherstellung fertigte der erfüllte in der folge dann sogar die verträge mit den deutschen
autobauern nicht mehr wohl um sich ganz auf die fertigung des model free zu konzentrieren nur so glaubte man die
ehrgeizigen ziele zu erreichen
5000 autos pro woche eine zahl die bei der fertigung von massenmodellen als minimum angesehen wird nur so kann kostengünstig
und effizient gefertigt werden doch nach dem start der produktion wollte das einfach nicht gelingen monatelang winkte er hinter den hochgesteckten
zielen hinterher im märz waren es
2500 in der woche dann im mai
3500 immer ein wenig mehr aber die 5000 wollten einfach nicht gelingen und das schien auch an mass nerven zu zerren
er meldete am ersten april die pleite von tesla
beantwortete fragen von journalisten einfach nicht und warf ihnen dummheit vor und beschimpfte
generell die medien sogar ein portal zur überprüfung der
glaubwürdigkeit von medien will ergründen naja zuletzt griff macht zu einigen drastischen maßnahmen errichtete kurzerhand eine zweite
produktionsstraße 1 allerdings fehlt neben zwei dinge dafür die maschinen und eine
produktionshalle die maschinen lese einfach von roman aus deutschland einfliegen ein teurer spaß und als
produktionshalle ließ er ein riesiges zelt größe zwei
fußballfelder aufbauen bevor diese die arbeiter schon in zwölf stunden schichten arbeiten damit hat er sein
produktionsziel jetzt zum ersten mal erreicht und zwar auf den punkt genau seine letzte ankündigung
lautete nämlich das produktionsziel wird ende juni 2000 18 erreicht du hast der belegschaft ist zu hören dass es zumindest nicht dauerhaft
gehalten werden kann zwölf stunden schichten sind einfach nicht dauerhaft mit einer hohen fertigungsqualität zu halten es bleibt also noch
einiges zu tun für die elektromobilität ist es allerdings ein riesenfortschritt
damit wird in den usa zum ersten mal ein elektroauto für den massenmarkt gebaut und das bedeutet auch weitere fortschritte für die technologie
bei den jüngst vorgestellten nächsten tesla fahrzeugen kommt offenbar eine neue
effizientere batterie technologie zum einsatz das autonome fahren würde immer weiter entwickelt und es werden auch davon wenn wir ja immer mehr
erfahrungen in der praxis gemacht batterie brände unfälle all das was bei neuen produkten passiert es ist also auch für die elektromobilität
einen riesenschritt man sehen welche veränderungen er bringt wenn er keine videos dazu und zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt dann hättet mich bei whatsapp
darum geht ihr die kaputte aber box hier auf youtube und verpasst kein video
denn über whatsapp erfahrt ihr von mir noch vor allen anderen vom neuesten video täglich und garantiert einfach hier
draufklicken und am besten auch meinen schwesterkanal blick zum social media abonnieren
da gibt es das neueste aus der social media welt dafür hier klicken aber nicht die
genau glocke vergessen und hier geht es weiter mit der haut drauf klicken elon musk
geheime batterie revolution bei tesla bis dann
bleibt dran